[Applause]
marion and i are so pleased you could
all come stay for the weekend
well the train ride wasn't too arduous
this is a very
linchpin scene for the movie because
it's showing a really
key component of hearst and hearse used
to
have these grand eloquent parties
where he kept his finger on the pulse of
culture
happy birthday to you
i mean you're getting a whole background
you're getting into what's your
politically of what's going on in the
[Applause]
[Music]
world
i remember reading the script in that
scene and it's sort of like like
turning the page and then turning the
next page and then turning the next page
and realizing how long it was
i will not demure that page count i look
at it as a
fun challenge we started by doing an
immense amount of research and we
actually found a lot of really great
research from the period in the day and
this particular room which was sort of
an assembly room
parlor was sort of a mess it was kind of
you know he actually had like a ping
pong table
and different things like that in there
this is 16th century man cave
yeah we wanted to keep order and romance
to it
so that it didn't feel so haphazard my
heart
is full to bursting i can't
express in words please don't try wr
nothing is more precious to me than your
friendship
and sage advice in the films that i've
worked on with david in the past we
have kind of developed a shorthand or a
style rather to
add lots of layers strangely enough in
this film
we concentrated oftentimes on taking
away
having less sound because we realize
that the more sound we had
the harder it was to really focus in on
all of the dialogue
and all the performances and there's so
many layers sound wise in terms of
dialogue
in the scene our country should be
flattered that you picked its birth date
as your own
the rest of us have to be satisfied with
the one we happen to be born on
here's to your rich canadian imagination
it was really just about figuring out
all of those camera positions and
figuring out how we were going to tell
that story
geometrically within the environment and
of course it's it's all done in deep
focus you know
there's good examples over gary's
shoulder looking back at marion
david you're not that keen on pickups
you get a rhythm
and you get a momentum going whereas
whether
just cutting in on something and picking
up something
you don't have that run-up it's like
trying to
stand in front of a hurdle and jump over
it
we all want to welcome the falbergs back
from irving's long
convalescence in europe thank you wr
good to see you orphan
thank you mr hurst norma anybody seen
anything good lately
i just saw 42nd street it blew
my wig you could take the girl out of
bad stuff
it was incredible everything comes into
how i played her all the preparation and
everything that's happening on the day
with the sets
the lighting the costumes everything of
course goes into it and
i'm just fed by all of it hopefully what
you're getting is
an evening around the campfire from 16
people who just met earlier in the day
got dressed for dinner and they've now
had cocktails and this is going to
continue on until pops goes to bed and
then the gin comes out and
who knows we end up with the neptune it
was like being in a play it feels
dynamic and cinematic but you've got to
live this life
for nine minutes with these characters
in this room and you don't often get
that there are probably four threads at
work
in this scene one is giving you life at
san simeon
and tonight we'll celebrate our great
friend's birthday
our little hillside home charlie
two is showing you the animosity between
some of the hollywood factions can't
last who in the world takes a lunatic
like that seriously well the last time i
looked
40 million germans meg you're always a
wonderful contrarian chess and sanborn's
der coffee
can 40 million nazis all be wrong i just
read they've opened their first
concentration camps
and started burning books what's next
movies is that true herbie yes i'll be
uh hitler schmidtler three it's showing
mary and she was the queen at san simeon
i love lowell thomas's voice oh is he
single
i sat across from him at the brown derby
once
he bought me a drink he didn't she was
also prone
to making mistakes i heard pops on the
phone
helping to pick the president's cabinet
like casting a movie
they can stop a guy like sinclair
couldn't you pop
pardon i don't know what i'm saying
and finally the scene as it eventually
you know
transitions to the outside
[Music]
it's about two people falling in
friendship with one another
and so the text is getting you a
dumpster load of
backstory but it's all sort of the
carrot
that drags the audience through it to
see herman and marion
alone and see his platonic
affairs
the bench we actually built and we
placed it in actually the exterior set
pieces were quite simple but in terms of
the radio
unfortunately there's a prop house
called history for hire and they had one
that
that we were able to use what is that
ah pop says radio phones never ever be
out of touch with your empire david got
us
very involved in just the acoustics of
that prop
because of the heaviness of that radio
and the gin and everything it's like
i need a very specific echo that makes
it sound like
marion is reaching deep within to get
her stashed and it has to have this
sonic signature i can't imagine david
wanting that
yeah exactly but it demonstrated the
texture of what it was that they're
sitting on it and it kind of reaffirmed
the fact that this is this marbled
texture
it was an interesting discovery for us
and we were adding those sounds to the
props
the one thing you never ever talk about
is upton sinclair i noted
the moment his mention the evening turns
it's sort of a sore subject
really do tell
the night scene was done day for night
and that required a lot of testing as
well
day for night is a cinema technique that
goes way back to the early days of
cinema
and it involves deliberately under
exposing the camera
so that the daytime looks like it's been
shot at night
and it's an old cinema technique that
we're winking at here a little bit
what do i have to complain about i live
in a fishbowl but anything i want is
mine
it's a strange scene the idea of
the button the rim shot from every
little passage
monkeys in their monkey business
elephants in their memories
giraffes and their long necks it was one
of the things you have to buy into i had
trepidations to the idea of having a cg
animal
a jab convinced me that this is what
these kinds of movies were like
and would indulge in these little things
that were
cartoony but pleasurable yeah it's
really it's
got great charm to it it's got the
animals are in on it nobody but
nobody makes a monkey out of william
randolph
first the sounds
of the giraffes was interesting because
we realized in our research that drafts
really don't make a sound not the most
vocal creatures yeah so we created
something
later on david decided he wanted to have
gary and amanda redo their dialogue and
so consequently this scene is 100
adr sorry
handstand my fault i was eight months
pregnant doing all my adr just a tito's
bottle
full of water the advantage that we had
with it you might
ordinarily look at it and think
absolutely like that's
that's a lot to do but the delivery of
the dialogue was very clean
and as much that there wasn't
naturalistic in that sense
we were just getting rid of leaf blowers
and rider rental trucks that were
backing up to move to the next location
so we weren't inventing anything we were
simply replacing
and because we had to loop all of the
dialogue we had to help the other crafts
the costumes the jewelry the footfalls
tell me something meg
the truth could you see me playing
elizabeth barrett browning or marie
antoinette irving's bought him both
i'd like to think that marion and i had
a similar approach to playing our
characters there's some things you just
don't notice that you're doing anymore
as an actor when you're really in
something
but you cannot hide her essence and i
love exploring this real person
and this real relationship that she had
a lot of it was
you know the biggest challenge of my
life thankfully but it was also easy in
some ways
her hair is gold her cheeks
roses nice her lips
her neck alabaster a bosom
marble maybe once i drew her hands
and her whiteness smell you wrote that
no a fella named cervantes it was one of
the best scripts i've read in a long
time
when you play a fictional character
you're making all that world up
but to be really honest with you i think
jack fincher had done a lot of obviously
done
a lot of that work he had captured
something on the page
emotionally psychologically the
character
was pretty much there there are
letters of accent letters of tone
the best of our letters is the letter
alone
now those i wrote if the writing's
really good then you follow the signs
it's much like a conversation amanda and
i would have
yeah it does it does feel of course it
feels natural as soon as we all cut
we're in different conversations
as amanda and gary and then yell action
you're back in the scene